>> Jason: WE ALL KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT THIS UPCOMING ELECTION
IS.
IN 130 DAYS, YOU WILL GET TO
DECIDE THE FUTURE OF THIS GREAT
COUNTRY.
FORMER SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE IN
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
NEWT GINGRICH IS THAT WITH A
BRAND-NEW BOOK TITLED TRUMP AND
THE AMERICAN FUTURE SOLVING THE
GREAT PROBLEMS OF OUR TIME.
NEWT SPOKE WITH SEAN EARLIER
THIS WEEK TO DISCUSS THE IMPACTS
OF THE SELECTION AND HOW IT
COULD FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE
AMERICA.
HAVE A LOOK.
>> WE WERE TALKING ON THE RADIO
THIS WEEK TALKING ABOUT HOW WE
FIRST MET IN 1990 AND YOU ARE
DOING A SPEECH IN DECATUR,
ALABAMA, AND YOU CAME ON IN OUR
HISTORY IS THE NIGHT YOU TOOK
BACK CONGRESS FROM REPUBLICANS
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 40 YEARS.
I KNOW WE SAY IT A LOT, AND IT’S
BEEN TRUE, BUT NOT AS TRUE AS IT
IS NOW.
I BELIEVE IF JOE BIDEN, THE
SOCIALIST AGENDA, THE NEW GREEN
DEAL FOREIGN POLICY IS
IMPLEMENTED, AMERICA BECOMES
UNRECOGNIZABLE, AND I DON’T
THINK THERE’S A WAY TO RECOVER.
THAT’S HOW CRUCIAL THIS ELECTION
IS.
>> THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
ELECTION SINCE ABRAHAM LINCOLN
IN 1860.
THAT’S A LONG TIME, BUT I DON’T
THINK IT’S JUST BIDEN, IT’S THE
MACHINE OF BIDEN, PELOSI, AND
SCHUMER.
WITH THE THREE OF THEM WOULD DO
THE MINUTE THEY HAD REAL POWER.
THEY WOULD DO EVERYTHING THEY
COULD IN THE VERY FIRST YEAR TO
TURN AMERICA TO CALIFORNIA TO
IMPOSE LEFT-WING VALUES ON ALL
OF OUR SCHOOLS TO REINFORCE AND
IT WOULD BE A TRULY CATASTROPHIC
ELECTION OUTCOME IF YOU ENDED UP
WITH BIDEN WITH PELOSI AND
SCHUMER IN CHARGE OF AMERICA.
>> I DON’T THINK WE SEE GROWTH
NUMBERS THIS FAST BASED ON THE
ECONOMY SHUTTING DOWN BUT WE ARE
SEEING THEM, SO LET’S ASSUME WE
HAVE HALF OF THE RECOVERY WHICH
WOULD BE UNPRECEDENTED JOB
GROWTH IN THIS COUNTRY AND ONE
OF THE GREAT AMERICAN COMEBACK
SUCCESS STORIES.
LET’S ASSUME THAT SOME OF THESE
DEEP STATE OPERATIVES THAT
PLOTTED AGAINST DONALD TRUMP ARE
PROBABLY INDICTED.
LET’S ASSUME THAT JOE BIDEN AT
SOME POINT HAS TO COME OUT OF
HIS BASEMENT AND I KNOW THAT’S
GOING TO HURT TERRY McCULLOUGH
WHO WAS FINE FOR HIM TO STAY
DOWN THERE FOREVER AND HE’S
ACTUALLY GOING TO HAVE TO TALK
AND EXPLAIN HIS RECORD AND I
DON’T THINK HE IS GOING TO DO
PARTICULARLY WELL, BUT THAT’S
JUST ME LOOKING INTO MY LITTLE
CRYSTAL BALL.
HOW DOES THIS ELECTION FALL OUT
IN YOUR VIEW?
IT’S HARD, YOU’VE GOT TO WIN
FLORIDA, OHIO, NORTH CAROLINA,
GEORGIA, PENNSYLVANIA,
WISCONSIN, MICHIGAN.
YOU’VE GOT TO LITERALLY RUN THE
TABLE IF YOU’RE A REPUBLICAN.
>> I DON’T THINK SO.
I’VE BEEN ACTIVE AS YOU KNOW FOR
A VERY LONG TIME.
I LIVED THROUGH THE ’84
CAMPAIGN, WAS AN ACTIVIST
CONGRESSMAN IN SAN FRANCISCO AT
THE DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION FOR
WALTER MONDALE, A SERIES OF
THESE THINGS.
WAS WITH GEORGE H.W. BUSH WHEN
HE WAS BEHIND BY 19 POINTS, THAT
WAS IN MAY, BEAT BY EIGHT POINTS
IN NOVEMBER WHICH MEANT ONE OUT
OF EVERY FOUR AMERICANS SWITCH
THEIR VOTE IN THAT PERIOD.
SO I THINK ONE OR TWO THINGS IS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
TRUMP MAKES A REASONABLE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY, NOT BACK TO
WHERE WE WERE, BUT MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION, AND IF HE DRAWS
A CLEAR CONTRAST NOT JUST WITH
BIDEN BUT WITH PELOSI, SCHUMER,
AND BIDEN AS A MACHINE, THAT IS
MUCH SCARIER AT THAT POINT, I
DON’T THINK IT WILL BE CLOSE.
I THINK WE WILL WIN BY A HUGE
MARGIN.
>> I AM GOING TO CLING TO YOUR
HELP BECAUSE IT IS NOTHING BUT